entier chaque année vous savez les
nouveaux formats qui se présente qui
sont achetés par les chaînes et les
producteurs et c'est vrai que cette
année est bien le marché a été assez
bons on a toutes les nouveautés alors
certaines sont déjà programmées d'autres
pas encore alors je sais pas si on doit
les attendre ou pas en tout les cas on a
enquêté
regardez comme chaque année beaucoup de
nouvelles émissions télé vont débarquer
sur nos écrans en france on vous en a
déjà parlé mais se massent singer arrive
très bientôt sur tf1
[Musique]
c'est à l'oeil show complètement déjanté
où des stars porteront des déguisements
spectaculaire pour dissimuler leur
identité sera animé par camille combal
autre talent show qui va débarquer sur
tf1 la chanson entre crête
une émission qui a déjà fait ses preuves
un peu partout en europe et chanteurs
ont su reprendre d'autres artistes en
faisant des cover de leurs plus grands
titres
on va faire une petite surprise à nico
france 2 quant à elle investi dans le
sport avec million dollar man un format
américain produit par la superstar du
basket lebron james onobiono dans cette
compétition les candidats vont se
mesurer à des athlètes de haut niveau
pour remporter de l'argent on vous en
avait déjà parlé mais ça se précise
l'émission d'arthur de zombies intitulé
district z est déjà en cours de
production salue l'audace d'arthur qui
pour le coup paraît très sûr de lui
l'univers sont bi est aujourd'hui ce que
le western était aux années 70 des zones
où il n'y a plus de loi ou la seule
chose qui compte est la survie voilà
pour les nouveaux formats qui arrivent
en france mais à l'étranger il existe
des émissions encore plus surprenantes
comme parental gaiden ou des parents et
puis en cachette leurs enfants et leurs
compagnons jusque dans l'intimité
toujours dans l'univers familial voici
family of hand c'est une émission des
couples doivent presser quelques jours
avec leur belle famille qui les
détestent
bref à la fin ils devront faire un choix
entre leurs finances et leurs familles
on reste dans le mariage avec worth
l'engagment ever une compétition qui
récompense la pire demande en mariage
est le meilleur pour la fin avec mon mec
porn littéralement maman fait du porno
un concept anglais complètement fou ou
des mamans vont explorer l'industrie du
sexe et devront même produire leurs
propres films de la réalisation au
casting classe chante son canapé why
pas sûr que cette émission-là débarque
en france alors que pensez vous de ces
nouvelles émissions c est ce qu il y en
a qui vous choque
[Applaudissements]
on a des extraits de me faisait peur
quand je vous dis alors c'est une
émission qui est totalement sauf ça n'a
rien à voir avec le monde de la
pornographie
s'il est vraiment à spa la tête des
états unis merci c'est vrai que c'est
une émission qui dont la caution giresse
et l'éducation sexuelle des enfants
ces violences ont leur on veut revenir
au sur les fonds en français vous avez
qu à arthur qui a créé un concept lady
qui s'appelle district z
qu'est ce que vous savez sur le fond à
mon chat maxime guinée stricte d'un
format une création 100 % régional
produit par satisfaction
la société de production d'arthur en
gros on vous jette des célébrités dans
un terrain vague dans un village
abandonné et des zombies vont tenter de
les attaquer donc lille seront imprimés
on va savoir leur rôle rythme cardiaque
en eau
l'idée d' arthur c'est de faire une
sorte de fort boyard tiers de créer ce
village est de faire venir les équipes
de tournage allait faire tourner un peu
tout ça c'est pas mal comme explication
mais en art show qui explique tout ça
avec ces voix là c'est un jeu d'aventuré
hot d'or et les doors qui est le premier
jeu d'aventuré auquel vont participer
des zombies
c'est un grand jeu d'aventuré il ya
plein d'épreuves et il faut sortir
vivant en moins de deux heures le set up
fait 10 hectares il ya un très gros
développements technologiques puisqu'on
aura les différents points de vue des
candidats sur une app la manière de
filmer va être différente
on veut se rapprocher d'un des jeux
vidéo donc ce sera entre de la
télévision et des jeux vidéo mais ça
reste une émission de télévision peut
tuer même ballon no one can be you
scream
[Applaudissements]
c'est financé à 100% par arthur il a dit
croire beaucoup je vous y croyez moi
dans mon piano nom alors je vais vous
dire le casting est magnifique je vois
on a reconnu tous jean reno bien sûr
qu'ils vont faire attendre les sept ans
il est dehors il a pris une sacrée
technique en tout cas les ha ha ha ça
c'est non il a fait un super boulot j'en
suis sûr mais moi c'est que ça me dit
rien les zombies mois limite c'est comme
quand on faisait la fête foraine moi je
vois zambie jeu le jeu le fera ou non
qu'on peut pas les femmes juste pour
info c'est que walking dead sur le câble
américain
les audiences le l'épisode 3 de la
saison sanofi c'était ou neuf c'était 45
millions il est aussi le phénomène un
peu moins ce phénomène n'est fait je
pense que ni toi ni moi moi c'est pareil
mais je dis quand même que j'y crois
parce que je suis sûr que ça m'a ramené
aussi certains jeunes à la télévision
ils ont envie de voir des jeux vidéos
qui sont sous forme d'émissions télé et
là franchement il a les yeux plus gros
que le ventre et on a envie on a hâte
sans moi j'ai hâte de voir ce que ça va
donner en vrai ils projettent déjà d'en
faire un jeu vidéo c'est vraiment mettre
dans cet univers-là et moi j'y crois
alors que je le regarderai ça me fait
peur
avec toi mais est-ce que les les zombies
à un film qui affaires locales et
séverine sur les zombies
voilà les morts ne meurent pas la
maîtrise de cinéma
benjamin alors en matière de jo lui
pardon moi je me pose là je sais mais
c'est ma passion
désolé pour fait du film de zombies ou
de la série zombies qui fonctionne c'est
basé sur la survie pas sur la recherche
d'un trésor où tout ça tout l'intérêt
d'un film de zombies ce ne sont pas les
zombies c'est juste les humains qui
s'entretuent s'entre déchirent pour
survivre là c'est pas le cas ça va pas
être le cas donc du coup c'est un contre
sens sur le concept alors est là et
scala chuck ya dans ce format là il ya
le formate sur le fond moustiques on en
a on en a parlé
comment le format des jolies de beurre
ils attendent comme mais il sait pas non
plus en reste sa façon plus serrée sauf
bien sûr si c'est pas ils ont dû céder
ici ça n'a rien à voir
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu arthur avec
vf l'audience alors elle est passée en
baisse c'est en dents de scie on va dire
c'est entendu si ça dépend des jours ça
dépend des fois ça dépend des inédits
c'est vrai que pendant quasiment tout
l'été ils ont diffusé toutes les
semaines c'est un peu ces deux formats
et ont testé jarry qui sait n'a pas vous
fonctionnez 600 milles 1 ils essayent de
soissons nouveau joker à arthur dans le
cas des tests qui sont faits mais
visible dans les nouvelles versions qui
ont été enregistrés récemment et ils ont
changé le mur infernal et il nous
apporte nouvelle c'est également ses
eaux usées quoi il faut les former
il a créé beaucoup beaucoup de formats
est ce que est ce que le défaut j'ai
peut-être de la chaîne
ces deux d'aller trop loin dans l'est
dans l'estomac t'embête est bon on a
compris ce qu'il fallait pas changer
passer aux bas puis c'est toujours les
mêmes c'est le même casting quand même
un bon je n'ai rien à sa bande arthur il
a sa borne donc on voit tout le temps
les mêmes le concept nous fatigue je
crois qu'il est vraiment temps de passer
à autre chose mais je suis pas ce serait
par ailleurs il aurait gîte ce soit
salvateur pour le vide en arrive à cette
semaine dans ma tête il a tout changé la
lame religieux des équipes cedrino
bientôt l'esprit mais bon c'est vrai que
reg arthur il doit il doit remonter
femme discrète alors il ya un format qui
arrive alors on en a parlé c'est masquer
singer oui vous avez vous avez des alors
les chanteurs qui arrête donc déguisés
qui sont jugés et en fait s'ils sont
reconnus et ben il va et bleu masse qui
sont hyper dur et s'ils sont pas
reconnus y reste deux semaines en
semaines avec leurs mains sur la tête
j'ai pas sommeil a des images aussi on
m'en remettre mais la voilà on les a
cédées superman ça j'y crois pas ça y
est c'est un format qui vient de corée
fermeture nouveau mais pas l'emploi mais
elle reconnaît pas leur voix
quand on connaît à chanter alors alors
la voie et rue et la voix la voix est
truqué quand il parle
mais la voix n'est pas truquée qui
chante alors je ne comprends pas parce
que si c'est pascal obispo je suis
désolé je suis alors à le reconnaître
deschamps alors que ça c'est pas des
senteurs sont des célébrités
oui j'ai eu des bruits comme quoi
l'émission est extraordinaire alors à
l'origine moi j'étais vraiment content
enfin je me disais c'est kitsch et
naseba et apparemment ça s'annonce comme
un truc top une très très curieuse de
voir cette émission de voir s'il va y
avoir d'abord les vraies célébrités
si les déguisements vont être à la
hauteur apparemment ils vont coûter très
cher donc on a envie de voir et surtout
camille combal dans cet exercice je
pense qu'il va s'éclater le problème ça
va être le casting parce que danse avec
les stars on l'a dit ici plein de fois
c'est quand même des stars qui sont pas
très très star
là ça va être intéressant si tout d'un
coup on découvre jean reno rue camille
lacourt s'il est bon mais bien les karma
format français à qui a cartonné pendant
les fêtes c'est la chance ou secrètes
oui avec près de 5 millions de
spectateurs lyon 8 eric a été un gars
qui étaient vendus au portugal aux
pays-bas en finlande en espagne en
italie on vous rappellera c'est regarder
jamais surprise générale c'est ce qui va
m'arriver je me suis un peu paniqué en
général je suis pas très surpris et
c'était très très longtemps que j'ai pas
autant stressé j'ai trahi leur cause je
ne suis pas ce qui se passe
ce soir c'est à
réac l3
cet âge là on va faire une petite
surprise a ni cause
chaque mois ci
[Applaudissements]
sans fausse note effectivement plein
plein de stars et moi mis à part le
moment avec nikos qui m'a vraiment
bouleversée j'ai chialé c'était très
émouvant pour le reste j'ai trouvé que
c'était téléphoner qui avait pas
vraiment d'émotion j'ai pas été hyper
surprise et je trouvais qu'il surjoue un
petit peu la surprise d un génial
oui mais ce n'est pas vrai vous êtes
bien des surprises pour le pour le petit
bémol diffusion pendant les fêtes
concurrence somme toute assez
j'ai quand même en face à ces faibles
colombie c'était la finale de ce boys en
face j'ai de quoi un format français de
création française se vend à
l'international surtout très très bon
signe sauf que là c'est très bas trop
cher
vous mettez un fauteuil ça coûte pas
énorme et je trouve ça mal hein parce
que ça va ça renouvelle un petit peu
quand même le genre d'erreur les
émissions reprise ça n'avait pas marché
dans la même année il y avait eu les
reprises de johnny hallyday les reprises
de goldman qui avait fait à peine trois
millions là ça faisait un million de
plus je trouve que c'était mal hein
parce qu'il n'y a pas énormément de
moyens ça marchait alors il ya un
nouveau format kyle pour le coup sur
france 2 qui s'appelle millions $ miles
il ya un problème le gouffre il ya un
truc c'est que l'émission était lancée
en amérique et l'émission était
déprogrammé
il se trouve que france 2 a commandé
deux saisons c'est que chaque épisode
qui font qu'il ya quatre épisodes sympa
saison ces huit cent mille euros
l'émission qu'elle soit 8 32 ça fait 1 3
million de voix de 2004
est-ce que france 2 de s'inquiéter et
quand même est-ce que kassim crédible
notre sage de jours est-ce que c'est pas
un budget un peu trop important pour le
service public et s'engager à ce point
là sur deux saisons
je pense que si on connaissait les vrais
budgets de france télévisions sur les
productions on aurait la langue qui
traînent par terre tellement les budgets
sont élevés donc je trouve à olivet way
que les budgets sont très élevés pour le
service public
à l'heure où on demande aux services
publics de faire de réduire justement le
train de vie le trendy justement des
émissions le coût des programmes
je pense que c'est un homme et dame trop
cher installez pelletreau choses et
format iphone est honnêtement je trouve
honnêtement je trouve pourquoi je dis ça
parce qu'on est en train de dire qu'il
faut on supprime la redevance alors tout
le monde est en train de demander donc
les chaînes pour du
service public demande d'augmenter de la
redevance elles sont assises sur la
redevance se sont france toutes les
chaînes de radio france mais aussi les
les chaînes de service de france télé
france 24 etc
elles sont assises sur la redevance je
pense qu'il ya d'autres endroits où on
peut investir au lieu d'investir autant
d'argent dans ce genre de jeu devenu on
n'est pas faire la course à l'audience
je donne une une info c'est qu'en fait
comme le producteur de millions de la
masse est le même qu'à faire car lui il
semblerait que il ya eu une espèce de
dessau ciation avec qui vous laisse le
programme qui fait passer les beaux
jours de france de l'après midi en
échange de quoi vous nous prenez ça et
si c'est vrai c'est en plus de ça ce
serait facile de le faire à l'économie
en ce moment à paris avec tous les
travaux chiayi préférées
[Applaudissements]